SPEWING FREEDOM OF SPEECH IS
AMERICA'S MOST DISTINCTIVE
RIGHTS.
IT'S A FREE COUNTRY.
THEY USED TO STAY
SAY THAT BACK WHEN IT WAS.
IT'S THE MOST AND BATTLED IN THE
NAME OF SAFETY AND SENSITIVITY,,
AND COALITION BIG TECH LOSS
WHAT YOU ARE ALLOWED TO SAY AND
PUNISH THOSE WHO STRAY OUT OF
THE ACCEPTED BOUNDARIES.
LAST YEAR COMEDIAN ADAM COROLLA,
WHO IS A GENIUS, AND RADIO HOST
DENNIS PRAGER, ALSO A GENIUS,
TEAMED UP TO RELEASE "NO SAFE
SPACES," A BRILLIANT DOCUMENTARY
ABOUT THE ANTI-AMERICAN
FREE-SPEECH UNIT.
>> ISRAEL SENT ME INTO THE 20
SOVIET UNION WHEN I WAS 21 YEARS
OLD BECAUSE I KNEW RUSSIAN AND
HEBREW.
HAD TO SMUGGLE IN RELIGIOUS
ITEMS AND SO ON.
I REALLY EXPERIENCED WHAT MOST
PEOPLE IN THE WEST HAVE NEVER,
EVER EXPERIENCED.
LIFE UNDER ITS VILLA TERRIEN
REGIME.
UNDER A TOTALITARIAN REGIME.
>> Tucker: IT'S A GREAT MOVIE
AND IF YOU WANT TO SEE IT IN
THEATERS, A LIMITED RELEASE THIS
WEEKEND THANKS TO STRONG SUPPORT
FROM DEDICATED VIEWERS.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR COMING UP AND
HAVEN'T TALKED TO YOU SINCE THE
FILM COME OUT.
START WITH YOU, ADAM, DID
ANYBODY TELL YOU YOU ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO SAY THE THINGS YOU
SAID IN THE FILM?
TO THE IRONY LOOP COME COMPLETE
DID THE IRONY LOOP COME
COMPLETE?
>> Tucker: IT'S INTERESTING
WHEN PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT
FREE SPEECH, BUT IT'S
FREE-SPEECH THEY WANT TO VET AND
MAKE SURE IT'S OKAY FOR THEM TO
HEAR BEFORE YOU CAN SAY IT.
I DID NOTICE THE CLIP WAS ALL
DENNIS PRAGER, BY THE WAY.
I'M GOING TO GET MY PUBLICIST ON
THIS.
>> THIS RESENTMENT IS A VERY BIG
PROBLEM.
>> Tucker: WELL...
>> IT'S A BIG PROBLEM.
WE ENJOY EACH OTHER TOO MUCH.
WE ARE LOOKING FOR PROBLEMS.
>> Tucker: WHAT ARE THE
PROBLEMS?
EVEN NEWLYWEDS, THEY MAY
SUBLIMATE IT BUT THERE IS
USUALLY TENSION.
IF YOU CAN IDENTIFY ONE THING
THAT DIVIDES YOU BITTERLY, WHAT
WOULD IT BE?
>> HE LIKES GEFILTE FISH, AND I
WOULDN'T BE THAT STUFF TO MY
CAT.
>> NO, YOU SAID YOU DID FEED IT
TO YOUR CAT FOR YOUR CAT LIKED
IT.
I ASKED HE SPECIFICALLY HOW IT
WENT OVER IN THE COROLLA HOME.
YOU SAID THE CAT LOVED IT.
>> Tucker: HE GAVE ME A JARGON
FILLED THE FISH.
BY THE WAY, FISH IS NOT SUPPOSED
TO BE IN JARS, IT SUPPOSED TO BE
ON PLATTERS OR ABOVE A FIREPLACE
IN A HUNTING LODGE.
>> Tucker: HAVE THE PROBLEMS
GOTTEN BETTER?
>> BETTER THAN IT'S EVER BEEN.
>> Tucker: WHEN I DO NOT THINK
THERE IS ANY IMPROVEMENT FOR
IMPROVEMENT AT ALL.
DO YOU THINK THE COUNTRY HAS
BEEN FREE OR LESS FREE SINCE THE
LAST --
>> NO, IT'S LESS FREE, NO
QUESTION.
THERE IS AN INTERESTING PROOF.
READ THE REVIEWERS IN THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA, NOT TO MENTION
LEFT-WING MEDIA, ON HOW THEY
HAVE CONTEMPT FOR THE FILM.
WHEN THE FILM FEATURES LIBERAL
AFTER LIBERAL, INCLUDING
PRESIDENT OBAMA, SPEAKING ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON ON CAMPUSES.
THEY CAN'T EVEN ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THIS IS GOING ON WHEN THEY SEE
THE FILM, WHICH IS ABOUT THE
SUPPRESSION OF SPEECH.
>> I HAVE A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
FEELING ON IT.
WELL, HERE'S WHAT I THINK.
I FEEL LIKE THE PENDULUM IS
STARTING TO SWING BACK THE OTHER
DIRECTION IN THE COMEDIC
COMMUNITY AND I FEEL A LOT OF MY
COHORTS IN THE COMEDY WORLD
STARTING TO PUSH BACK AGAINST IT
BECAUSE THEY ARE AT THIS
SATURATION LEVEL AND I FEEL LIKE
THE GROUP THAT STARTED THIS
THING IS STARTING TO DOUBLE DOWN
ON IT.
STARTING TO REALLY WORK IT
HARDER.
SORT OF THE SAME SUBJECT AS
RACISM, AS RACISM FADES FROM OUR
SOCIETY, A CERTAIN GROUP IS
TRIPLING DOWN THEIR EFFORT TO
MAKE SURE IT'S ALIVE AND WELL,
OR AT LEAST WE THINK IT'S ALIVE
AND WELL.
>> I THINK HE'S RIGHT ABOUT THE
COMEDIC COMMUNITY.
OUTSIDE OF THAT, I DON'T THINK
IT'S TRUE.
SAN FRANCISCO 49er COLOR
ANNOUNCER -- I'M NOT SURE YOU
CAN USE THE TERM ANY LONGER,
SIMPLY SAID IN DESCRIBING THE
BALTIMORE RAVENS' QUARTERBACK
WHO WAS IT TO TERRIFIC
QUARTERBACK AND HIS BLACK, SAID
THERE MIGHT BE THIS SLIGHT HALF
SECOND ADVANTAGE IN THE HANDOFF
BECAUSE THE BALL IS BLACK AND
THE UNIFORM IS BLACK AND HE IS
BLACK, SO THE OFFENSIVE LINE
DOESN'T SEE IT QUITE AS QUICKLY.
THE GUY SAID YOU ARE A RACIST
AND UNLESS HE APOLOGIZED
PROFUSELY AS IN MAO'S CHINA IN
THE CULTURAL REVOLUTION, HE
WOULD'VE LOST HIS JOB.
>> DEFENSIVE LINE.
BIG DEFENSIVE LINE, YOU ARE
RIGHT.
>> Tucker: BUT THE POINT
REMAINS.
WHAT ABOUT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
FACING THIS PROBLEM -- NOT JUST
FAMOUS PEOPLE BUT NORMAL PEOPLE
UNDER ATTACK BY THE HR
DEPARTMENT DOWN THE HALL?
WHAT IS THE RIGHT RESPONSE FOR
THEM?
SHOULD THEY GO THROUGH MAO'S
CHINA ROUTINE WHERE THEY
APOLOGIZE AND BEG FORGIVENESS,
OR DO THEY STAND UP FOR
THEMSELVES?
>> I DO NOT KNOW WHAT ADAM'S
POSITION IS ON THIS, BUT I
THINK -- FIRST OF ALL,
APOLOGIZING MEANS THAT YOU THINK
YOU ARE WRONG.
I DID NOT KNOW HOW PEOPLE LIVE
WITH THEMSELVES WHEN THEY ARE
RIGHT AND THEY PUBLICLY
ANNOUNCED THAT THEY WERE WRONG.
IT'S SO HUMILIATING THAT I
PERSONALLY COULDN'T DO IT.
>> I THINK WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO DO IT THIS WAY BECAUSE I DO
MY OWN PODCAST, I HAVE MY OWN
PIRATE SHIP, I HAVE AUTONOMY, I
CAN SAY WHAT I WANT.
I DON'T HAVE TO APOLOGIZE.
THUS, I AM NOT ASKED TO
APOLOGIZE BECAUSE I NEVER
APOLOGIZE.
BUT FOR GUYS WHO DO, ANNOUNCERS
FOR THE 49ers, WHAT ARE THEY
TO DO?
>> IT'S A HORRIBLE DILEMMA.
SPEAK WHAT WE HAVE TO DO IS STOP
APOLOGIZING AT THE SAME TIME.
THAT MEANS THERE'S ONE GUY WITH
A GUN.
WE JUST HAVE POOL CUES AND WE
ALL HAVE TO CHARGE THEM AT ONCE.
IF WE DO IT ONE BY ONE, WILL BE
TAKEN OUT ONE BY ONE.